hey what's up guys Mary here at PAX East
2016 I'm here with Tony hello how's it
going and you just saw a
much-anticipated sequel Shadow Warrior 2
yes I did
so you played it on PC did you not I
played it on PC it's also coming to ps4
and Xbox one at some point this year
very cool so now a lot of people love
the original Shadow Warrior which is
probably why it's getting a sequel and
they love the level design but there's
something different in this game yes the
first game is very linear I shouldn't
even say very it's a hundred percent
linear but Shadow Warrior 2 every single
mission all 29 are going to be
procedurally generated so the mission I
play today it's gonna have the same
objectives you know I have to collect
these things that could kill this giant
fire demon but the place I want to do is
objectives it's gonna change for
everybody in fact I could look around at
the demo stations and see oh that guy is
playing a knife it's if there are
different weather effects on this guy
station so it's different for everybody
and what's fantastic is that it doesn't
feel procedurally generated this feels
like everything is purposely put here
because hit and run across these
rooftops hey I can climb up this cliff I
can jump off of this bridge and and jump
down on some demons but it's all
procedural which i think is fantastic
yeah and you something that we always
see with procedural games is you always
have to ask yourself is it fun playing
once because if it's not then doesn't
matter if it's procedural because it
wasn't enjoyable the first time but this
game seems to be really hooking people
with these really fun moments and of
course it's got a really really great
shooting so when we talk about that for
a bit
oh it feel it the shooting feels so good
it feels just if you're a fan of quake
Unreal Tournament that sort of shooting
good night absolutely that is what this
feels like it's not tactical Call of
Duty it's not battlefield it is go in
there shoot stuff spray blood spray
bullets it just feels so good I'm a big
fan of shotguns I go for one every time
and there's there's just there was just
a satisfaction not just with the shotgun
but with every weapon where I'm just
blowing away these demons what other
weapons can people
so I was using a shotgun there is of
course your your pistols your machine
guns there was also this sort of poison
cursed green looking skull rifle that
did that did yes I'm sort of cursed
damaged you've got melee weapons you've
got this like katana and these sort of
Wolverine claws I guess it's gonna be
the best way to describe them and you
have powers on the d-pad so you can like
impale a guy on a spike you can heal
yourself you can it is sort of a go
invisible kind of thing and almost look
like predator vision where I could like
escape from enemies so you just got all
these tools to just destroy things and
it just feels so fun so there's a lot of
different options in what you can do in
the levels and there's 29 missions is
that correct
29 missions is what I was told you're
gonna have the same objectives every
time but what the actual level looks
like is gonna be different for you
because it's a procedural alright sweet
well that was Shadow Warrior 2 and that
is coming in an unknown date this year
sometime this year is what they say
you